hey guys before we get started with the
game i want to let you know that cloak
has new
shirts book his new shirts for pride
month
they're great we also have hoodies hats
and shorts and best of all half of all
proceeds are going towards the trevor
project so go to cloakbrand.com or click
in the link in the description below
and find some for yourself thanks so
much and back to the game hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome back to five nights at freddy's
vr
i am just about done with your [ __ ]
buddy
i liked the music cut off there because
i wanted to reiterate my point with some
definite
severity but we need to go into the
chunk
wishy-washy nightmare world where you've
got a little more substantiation to you
huh buddy huh don't you now i know that
i have not been the best about getting
all of the tapes and the yada yada and
the what that and i i still don't know
what this button do
nor do i think i want to know what that
button do but i don't know what that
button do can that music not be so ear
scratchingly horrifying
so what i'm gonna do is i'm not gonna go
to the basic five nights at freddy's
levels
mostly just because i really wanna see
and i feel like i've earned the ability
to pick and choose which one i go to
next i want to see how these
change because bonnie in this picture
really grabbed my attention
and i don't know how it's going to be
trying to change out a horrifying
nightmare version of
body or why this is just some bizarre
nightmare world anyway but
here we go
whoa [ __ ] god damn it's in service
oh no it looks like bonnie's guitar is
out of tune and must be recalibrated
okay first we must access his
harmonization module
located inside his secondary throat pipe
to access the throat pipe
both eyes must first be removed great
you must be as precise as possible
when removing the eyes from their
respective sockets what the hell first
firmly grip bonnie's left eye and
carefully remove it from its socket
wait so what's different about it then
besides the really messed up music
you said no okay so it's the same coin
that i got before
doesn't even exist anymore i guess okay
left eye your left
eye don't mess with me buddy because
i ain't about this [ __ ]
you got a you got a weird face and i
don't like it oh my god
okay everything's fine
great job thank you was it the left eye
and the cleaning receptacle on your left
you got it well done now
firmly grip bonnie's right eye and
carefully remove it from its socket
sounds good to me buddy i like it can i
have this please can i has this
the right eye in the cleaning receptacle
on your right great
good job to open bonnie's face plate
carefully press the two buttons located
on either side of bonnie's jaw
all right you're not gonna mess with me
this time because i know
what you do when i do this
i have access to bonnie's harmonization
module
secondary throat pipe to enter
calibration mode
okay
something is not right one of those
notes is out of tune
right push the button again to replay
the audio check
i know which one it was a colored button
that corresponds to the incorrect press
the blinking button again to verify your
work
great job bonnie is in tune and ready
for his solo
let's close him up simply replace both
eyes in the same order that you removed
them
then close up the faceplate and we'll
call it a day
all right just that easy huh
not much different going on here all
feels the same actually
well done that concludes your parts and
services task
see you next time oh okay
wait wait is that it what the [ __ ]
wait me bites extra-large
absolutely incredible i do agree but
hang on i'm very confused
maybe i had a complete misunderstanding
of what this was all gonna entail
because what the hell that was exactly
the same that was the same thing except
it's all freaky and weird
but why is it all freaky and weird is
there something else i'm not
understanding about all this
welcome back whoa what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god you just moved rummaging
around the kitchen again
you just moved in remove all the food
particles from exterior
and place it in the refuse space oh i
see you
oh i see you okay all right then refuse
spin it
is give me that give me some of this
i'll take that no problem to open her
beak
carefully press the two uh-huh
[ __ ] i i [ __ ] swear to god i
[ __ ]
to clear the emphasis yeah yeah i know i
remember the chemistry
now reattach chica's upper arm hand and
cupcake plate
can i have this why can't i not have
this
there we go okay just like that
okay and the doinkest you're
fine oh no it looks like the kimmy spray
is no longer oh wait why why why to come
back the infestation
take them off by hand where's the
cupcakes to chica's place
wait wait what the [ __ ] okay so anyway
okay all right i don't know where the
cupcake is the cupcake on the plate
where the [ __ ] did the cupcake go oh
come back here no no
no oh oh you get kicked replace the guy
great job [ __ ] chica is ready to serve
pizza and hugs to the kids again
take a complimentary slice of pizza for
a job well done
okay is there something hiding under the
pizza
go on take it what if i don't what
happens if i don't how about what if i
don't
i don't know if i want i'm not hungry i
don't know if i like pizza are your eyes
oh yeah
i well don't tell me to eat it that's
just rude number one
number two eat it i oh i i don't wanna
eat it
[ __ ] god oh really
eat it oh [ __ ] you you know what [ __ ]
you oh you
look what the [ __ ] wait wait wait what
what the [ __ ]
wait a minute what the [ __ ] what's with
the cables
and why are there three does one go on
the tv what the [ __ ] is that about
whoa i'm gonna run that by me again
what the [ __ ] ah freaking what the [ __ ]
off
you piece of [ __ ] oh prick huh
fine whatever god screwed you god this
stupid cable i don't know why this
stupid cable's giving me come back
whatever yeah i know i know i know i
know i
great job chica is ready to serve pizza
and hugs to the kids again well could
chow to you and kachow to me for a job
well done
well if you weren't talking over me i
would have said kachow to you and uh
ciao
i take two would it be bad probably bad
if i took two
what if i ate the whole pizza
oh what the hell look at you
tubby little snot oh look at their gucci
gucci
oh wow your voice is different than i
thought it'd be why
what's wrong with my voice doesn't it
match my cuddly doubly body no
not necessarily as much as i thought it
would oh
so many things you might misconstrue
about my
appearance but looks can be deceiving
okay all right why do you got to say
everything's so creepy no reason at all
i'm just trying to be charming okay i i
don't like where the
i got too into that is the problem with
that one
i don't know what came over me all right
mr parts oh
[ __ ] why every time what the [ __ ]
guests
left a person on our star attraction
let's return it to the lost and found
what the hell
carefully grab and remove the child's
hat from freddie's mouth what the hell
what the hell
what the hell be careful not to touch
any of freddy's sensitive wiring
i don't know if i can get my hand that
deep in there there we go got it
thank you a replacement may be found on
the world come on come on get in there
okay am i good am i good that couldn't
take
your time in parts and services holy
[ __ ] you'll be docked accordingly
what the hell
what the hell oh pirate plunder bar
a treasure trove of taste
delicious and nutritious i got the
lottery on this one
i don't like being in this world i feel
like i'm peering too much behind the
curtain
and also why do those curtains raise
that one time forever ago
okay all right last last one they're not
functionally different but
everything is so just messed up here i
think after this what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go and try to find
the other tape back to parts and
services [ __ ] swear
and place foxy's head on his
endoskeleton
oh oh oh
no oh oh oh oh
oh [ __ ] i didn't mean to do that i
didn't mean to do that
ah
i thought this is going to be doing a
playful goof jumpsuit
what the [ __ ] was that do that again
do that again ah [ __ ] you yeah i get out
of
here
you will need to place new control fuses
in the exposed receptacles to continue
wait what retrieves the fuse from that
matches foxy's leg receptacle
why are they changed like that i don't
like that
oh well fine you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up come here you [ __ ]
come on come on
fine if that's how you are if you're not
gonna be polite about it then i'm not
gonna be polite about it either
get me out of here get get me out of
here get me
out of here i've had just about enough
with your
badass oh what's the [ __ ] out of
control do i put it on my head
a series of simple repairs
what did i put that on my head
i didn't know i could do that
[Applause]
i didn't know i could do that in
condition oh god i can put it off
carefully pick up
and place foxy's head on his
endoskeleton no i'm busy with it
i'm busy hey hey turd nugget
hey douche nozzle hey loser hey
[ __ ] hey stupid fool what are you
gonna do about it hey
i got the power now what do you think of
this i got the
power yeah whatever you can't get me i
got your head
what are you gonna do stuff me in an
endoskeleton can't
what are you gonna do about it nerd get
with the program
loser yeah suck some of this
dong okay this this is the inner one
definitely oh [ __ ] there we go whoo
that's a close one place the eye back
into his eye socket
okay
this concludes all your parts and
service tasks
i don't think it should be reopened like
this but you know you do
you you feel what you want to do and
i'll
oh i'll listen all right hey wow
it's me bonnie oh bonnie
hi man you're you are wade's apparently
nemesis
oh wow i don't know why he thinks that
i kill everybody oh okay well you know
we're all good after i repaired you
right
oh yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] god
why can't you eat that one why can you
eat that one i
i swear i'm not trying to i didn't even
think about that
i completely forgotten that you could
eat them
hi how are you good great well
that's another one down did all of them
easy peasy i'm gonna go back into the
real world you know
boink you're still there yes you are
you're getting a little more visible i
see you okay so
what i'm going to do next there's
there's like something going on here
something going on and it is going to
require me to get those
tapes and the coins so i'm sure there's
got to be some guide out there that
tells exactly where those are
so my next mission before i even
continue doing any of these ones which i
will i'll do these
it looks like they're not too much
terribly did more difficult
i mean the these are probably the fnaf
ones are but we'll see wait night
terrors what the [ __ ] wait no
what oh [ __ ]
oh no in order to get that you got you
probably gotta beat everything
yeah okay all right okay um well we got
that to look forward to but i'm gonna
look up
where those things are and i'm gonna get
those in the next episode but thank you
everybody so much for watching
be on the lookout for more fnaf videos
coming at you as soon as you can
subscribe and ring the link that bell if
you want to know exactly when where and
why
check out the description for more links
to cool videos that i've made
in the past and thank you everybody for
watching and as always
i will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you